lo que sabemos de la muerte de Armando
el jefe de vídeo de la agencia afp aquí
en Ucrania desde el pasado septiembre es
que se encontraba en la población de
chasillar está ubicada a 10 km de bacmut
y desde hace ya meses también es parte
del centro de batalla de esta región del
la ciudad es atacada constantemente la
mayoría de la población es evacuada y
allí estaba ayer este equipo de afp que
según las nuevas regulaciones para la
prensa en Ucrania tiene que tener un
permiso especial y estaban según
entendemos con un jefe de prensa de una
de las brigadas destinadas a la zona
entendemos que estaba caminando por una
de las calles principales de esta
población cuando fueron atacados por
estos cohetes que tienen la
característica de que vienen uno tras
otro lo que hace más difícil poder
correr y escon todos se tiraron al piso
pero fue Armada en el que fue alcanzado
por uno de estos cohetes y falleció pues
después de esto el resto de sus
compañeros salieron y le esos Pero toda
la agencia ha mostrado un gran pesar por
la muerte de este hombre de 32 años que
había nacido en sarajevo más adelante
había emigrado a Francia donde se había
nacionalizado y todos lo llaman como un
gran reportero apasionado por contar lo
que sucede allí donde donde está la
noticia especialmente desde que comenzó
esta invasión a gran escala aquí en
Ucrania fue uno de los primeros en
llegar y ha pasado mucho tiempo en esta
región del donbadas donde se libran
algunas de las principales batallas solo
hace pocos días Él publicaba en sus
redes otro vídeo en el cual también
estaba en el si habían sido atacados por
otros cohetes él había dejado correr
Este vídeo y se mostraba
lo difícil de las circunstancias y él
decía que pocas veces había pasado
momentos tan duros con armazón al menos
11 periodistas y productores locales que
han muerto desde el comienzo de esta
invasión a gran escala